I want you to take responsibility so a
friend of mine has a young person in his
life and he wants this young person to
grow and he's afraid that this young
person doesn't have the right people
around him and given him the wrong
advice and and he feels helpless my
friend feels helpless because he feels
like what kind of impact can he have
because he's not this person's parent
he's not this person you know best
friend he has a he's related but he
doesn't have a big impact or so he feels
and he feels like I can't do anything
you know I really want to help I feel
for this person I really want to help
what I can't do anything cuz I'm not his
dad you know I'm not his friend I don't
see him every day and he feels hopeless
he feels hopeless because he can't make
an impact and here's the thing the
second that you think that you can't
have an impact that you can't make a
difference you've lost as soon as you
abdicate responsibility as soon as you
tell yourself well I can't make a
difference it's on his parents you know
it's on his friends it's on the people
in his school it's on people in his
environment as soon as you tell yourself
that you've lost the mena that you
accept our sensibility that's when
things start to change that's when
impact starts to happen because we've
all had people in our lives we're just a
brief experience with them a brief
encounter with them has changed who we
are whether it's somebody at school
whether it's an advisor whether
something that we've just looked up to
on youtube or on TV or you read a book
that person thinking changed who we are
you could be that impact on somebody
else's life that could be you and it's
just accept your responsibility and you
can start by trying to have an impact on
the parents right trying to explain to
them your point of view you could try to
have an impact on his teachers try to
have an impact on his friends and
explain your point of view and show how
much you care and show how much you love
and show them you know what their
actions are having a name
act on his life but even if you can't
like even if you can't reach his parents
you can't get through to them even if
you can't get through to his his
teachers or the people in his class you
can't make any kind of break through to
the people in of lives you can still
have an impact you can still have an
impact by being present in that person's
life you would have a 15 minute phone
call with him daily or go see him once a
week in that brief encounter that brief
having somebody who believes in you who
sparks you who challenges you who makes
you feel like you can do anything that
makes a difference you could be that
different and the same thing happens
entrepreneurs the entrepreneur's don't
get any where are the entrepreneurs who
blame other people all right the reason
why you're not successful is because of
your parents or because of the school
system or because of the government or
because of the economy or because of the
currency or because of something right
it's always somebody else's fault is
ever your fault of course not it's
always somebody else's fault and as long
as you place the blame on other people
then you're never going to grow you're
never going to grow and as soon as you
accept responsibility for your life to
say I can make this better this is on me
the reason why I'm not achieving my
goals is because of something inside
myself and the stories I'm telling
myself as soon as you stop blaming other
people and accept that responsibility
that's when you started to see growth
that's when you start to see momentum
and I'm tired of people complaining I'm
tired of people just placing blame on
other people you know you're tired of
your country being the way it is don't
blame the politicians blame yourself
start making the change what are you
doing and make your nation better what
are you doing to make your city better
what are you doing to make your friends
and family better what are you doing to
make your business better what are you
doing to build up the people around you
you can have an impact as long as you
believe you can have an impact so stop
placing blame start accepting
responsibility and start getting some
momentum I'm walking home it's dark I
apologize with a little quality of the
footage I'm just pissed off and one
thing I learned is when you're excited
that's when you should get out the
camera and make a video so that's it let
me find some light that's it have a
great day guys continue to believe
and I'll see you soon